this is cereth registered nurse ari
ENCOM and in this video i'm going to
demonstrate how to perform a head and
neck assessment now if you would like to
see a complete head-to-toe assessment
you can check out this card up here in
the corner or in the youtube description
below to access the video on how to do
that now before you do a head and neck
assessment you'll want to provide
privacy wash your hands and explain to
the patient what you'll be doing and
you'll want to gather your supplies
you'll need an otoscope to look at the
ears a tongue blade to look in the mouth
a pin light to assess the eyes and
gloves so let's get started we are first
going to inspect the head and we are
looking at the skin color he it's nice
and pink we're also going to make sure
that the head is the same size as how it
should be for the body and it is and
we're looking for any abnormal movements
or twitching of the face that he can't
control that are involuntary and we
don't see anything and we're making sure
that the face is symmetrical there's no
drooping on one side like in this
picture there's drooping on one side of
the face and this can be seen in Bell's
palsy or in stroke and we're also just
looking at the eyes in the ears or they
have the same level and while we're here
we're going to go ahead and look at the
facial expressions and test cranial
nerve seven which is the facial nerve so
can you close your eyes tightly for me
and open them up okay now smile for me
frown and puff out your cheeks okay and
he did that with E so that cranial nerve
is intact next what we're gonna do is
we're gonna palpate the head the cranium
we're gonna check for any masses
indentations look for skin breakdown any
infestations and for this part I like to
wear gloves so let's look at the hair so
what we're doing is we're filling for
any masses indentations and also with
this we're looking for any skin and
breakdown and if your patients and
mobile you really want to check the back
of the head back here because they're
laying on it a law and there can be
break down back there also while you're
doing that
look inside the hair make sure there is
no infestations like lice and there's no
abrupt like rounding areas of baldness
which could represent alopecia then
after that since this patient has a
beard you want to check the beard as
well any lesions any infestations or
anything like that and just look around
and then once you're done with that what
you want to do is you'll doff your
gloves and perform hand hygiene next
what we're going to do is we're going to
find the temporal artery and we're going
to palpate them bilaterally and they are
both found right here and that his are
about a 2 plus and then while we're
right there we're gonna go ahead and
test cranial nerve 5 which is the
trigeminal nerve and this nerve is
responsible for many things like
massification so what I want to have you
do B in is I want to have you clench
your teeth like bite down for me and I'm
going to feel the Meseta muscle which is
right there this should be a nice firm
ball and then feel the temporal muscle
now what I'm going to do to also test
that nervous have him try to open his
mouth against resistance so try to do
that for me okay and he can do that now
while we're here we're going to go ahead
and feel the temporal mandibular joint
and we're gonna feel right here I'm
gonna have you open and close your mouth
and I'm feeling for any grading or
clicking sensations and I feel none then
we're gonna palpate the sinuses and I'm
going to put pressure on these two
sinuses right here and you tell me if
you feel any pain okay so the max max
look maxillary yeah in the frontal
though next we're moving down to the
eyes and we're going to inspect the eyes
first and we're looking at several
things we're looking at the eyelid we're
looking at the sclera which is the white
of the eyes we're looking at the iris
we're looking at the pupil and we're
looking at the conjunctiva so you
shouldn't see any swelling of the
eyelids you should see that the sclera
is Y and shiny it shouldn't be yellow
like in jaundice and the conjunctiva
when you pull down the lower lid have
don't look up it should be nice in pink
it shouldn't be red you shouldn't see
any drainage or anything like that in
look at the eyes how do they set in the
eye socket is are they equal four
instances is there any strabismus is
there a cross eye where one eye turns in
more turns out or up or down and these
eyes are normal there's no strabismus
next you want to look at anisocoria
where you have where one pupil would be
smaller than the other people are they
equal in size normal pupils should be 3
to 5 millimeters in their measurement
and here his are about a 3 and they are
equal next what we're gonna do is we're
going to assess some cranial nerves
we're gonna be looking at cranial nerve
three which is ocular motor for troq
Euler and then 6 which is abducens and
we're gonna do several tests to check
their function the first one what we're
going to do is we're going to be looking
for any involuntary shaking of the eye
called nystagmus and how we're gonna do
that was we're gonna take our pin light
we're gonna hold it about 12 to 14
inches away from the patient's nose and
then what I want you to do is keep your
head still don't move your head and just
use your eyes to watch where I move the
pin line and as you're doing this you're
going to do you're going to perform it
in the six cardinal fields of gaze and
you're just going to move it you're
looking for any involuntary shaking of
the eyes so here we go
next we're going to see how reactive the
pupils are to lie and to do that we're
gonna dim the lights a little bit and
we're gonna have the patient's stare off
at a distant object that helps dilate
those pupils and then we're going to
shine using our pin light in at the side
and we're gonna see how that pupil
response is she constrict and then on
the other side it should constrict as
well so say their baseline pupil size
was like three millimeters it should go
down to one milliliter and it should
happen on both sides okay so being stare
off at that object rod on the wall over
there for me okay and that dilates the
pupils and we're just going to shine
light in at this side okay constrict
constrict okay I'm dilate again then go
over to the other side do the same again
and they both constricted and equal size
next what we're gonna do is we're gonna
check for accomodation and how we do
that is we turn the lights back on we
just previously had them dim but we now
make it light again we're gonna have him
stare off at a distant object that helps
dilate the pupils and we're gonna take a
pin like you can use a pin light finger
and you're just gonna slowly move it
inward to the nose and what you're
looking for is that those pupils
constrict they accommodate and the eyes
cross while looking at the pin line so
here we go stare off in the distance
please and I don't want you to move your
head or anything just keep it real still
and just follow this pin light okay
ready
okay so now we can document because we
just checked all of the things with the
eyes we can document that the pupils are
equal round reactive to lie in the
accommodate so that's where that acronym
perrla comes into play next we're going
to move on to the ears so first what we
do is we inspect the ears we look on the
outside of the ear is there any
abnormalities any redness any drainage
anything like that and then are you
having any pain in your ear okay and
sometimes if you have patients who've
had long-term gout on the helix of the
ear they may have what's called a Toph I
which is an accumulation of like a
whitish yellowish uric acid crystals on
the skin so if you ever see that that is
what that looks like next we're going to
palpate on the ear we're just gonna move
it around and then tell me if you have
any tenderness whenever I do that and
any feel any abnormal masses or lesions
and then move the targets a little bit
does that hurt or anything like that
okay so no pain or tenderness then we're
going to palpate the mastoid process
which is the big behind the ear and
we're looking at it is it swollen is
there any redness and whenever I touch
on it again does it hurt okay and just
see if the patient reports any
tenderness with that then when you're
there you can use the otoscope to
inspect the tympanic membrane and
remember the tympanic membrane should be
a pearly gray translucent color and
should be shiny so for an adult you're
going to pull the pin of the ear up and
back and we're just going to inspect it
and also while we're looking at that we
are looking at the cone of light and
remember the cone of lie and the right
ear should be at five o'clock and in the
left ear should be at seven o'clock next
we're gonna do one more thing with the
ear we're gonna test cranial nerve eight
which is the best tibula
cochlear nerve and what I'm going to do
is I'm going to include one of his ears
and then whisper two words on the other
side he needs to tell
me what I said so you ready okay I'm
gonna clued this one okay very good okay
and that nerve is intact next we're
gonna move on to the nose and we're
going to inspect the nose we're gonna
make sure its midline on the face which
it is we're gonna look at the septum is
it deviated anything like that and ask
the patient or you have any trouble with
your nose are you having any drainage or
anything like that no and you want them
to make you want to check the patency of
the nose I mean I'm gonna have you
include one side of the nostril breathe
out of the other and vice versa
okay heard airflow airflow nice and
Paton because sometimes people can have
polyps that can block it or the deviated
septum then you want to take your pin
light and you just want to look inside
the nose look for any drainage redness
or any like polyps or anything like that
and everything looks clear don't see
anything and then we're going to test
the olfactory cranial nerve one the
sense of smell so Ben what I'm gonna
have you do is I'm gonna have you close
your eyes and I'm gonna put something in
front of your nose and have you breathe
in and smell and you tell me what you
smell and whenever you do this use
something that's pleasant smelling not
something that's really stinky cuz it
could elicit like a gag reflex or
something like that if the person has a
sensitive nose okay okay and this was
vanilla extract and that's correct
so that cranial nerve is intact next
we're gonna move on to the mouth and for
this part like to wear gloves and if
your patient is coughing and hacking you
might want to wear a mask with a shield
so you don't get any mucus on your face
or in your mucous membranes so first
what we're gonna do we're just
inspecting the lips make sure they're a
nice pink color they're not chapped
there's no sores on them and when
thing with a lot of patience whenever
there oxygen saturations our load their
lips may turn dusky or a blue color so
you want to make sure they're nice and
pink cuz that can represent our oxygen
level now let's inspect the inside of
the mouth but first let's test cranial
nerve 12 which is the hypoglossal nerve
and what I'm gonna have you do being is
I'm gonna have you stick out your tongue
and move it side to side okay and he
does that with ease now what we're gonna
do is we're going to inspect the inside
the mouth you'll need a tongue blade for
that and just open up your mouth for me
and I'm gonna look on the inside of the
cheeks nice and pink don't see any sores
you're looking to see if they're nice
and pink and there's no lesions or
anything like that and stick out your
tongue for me the tongue should be moist
like this and pink you don't want to be
beefy red which is like an pernicious
anemia you don't want to be dry or crack
that can be dehydration okay you can put
the tongue yep then I want you to lift
up your tongue for me and look for any
lesions underneath the time
that's where mouth cancer can hang out
and I don't see any okay you can close
then you'll why you're also looking at
the gums open up a little bit you're
gonna look around for cavities any loose
or broken teeth no dental caries in
there then okay so to open up your mouth
a little bit more put your tongue down
and you're gonna look at the soft and
hard palate now while you're in there
you want to look at the uvula make sure
it is nice in midline and his is nice
and midline and we're going to test
cranial nerve nine the glaucio
pharyngeal and so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna have you say ah and what you
want is that you've left to move up okay
and then we're just gonna test the gag
reflex I'm sort of just gonna poke a
little bit back there and elicit a gag
reply okay there you go
cats really good and cranial nerve 10
the vagus is intact because he's able to
talk with some talk to me without
hoarseness and he's able to swallow then
when you're done inspecting the mouth be
sure you take off your gloves and
perform hand hygiene now moving on to
the neck so what we're going to do is
we're going to inspect the neck for
so you're gonna have the patient extend
the neck up a little bit and you're
looking at that trachea is it midline
look for any lesions and look for any
lumps like what you might see and
thyroid problems like AG order and we
don't see any of that then what we're
gonna do is we're gonna test cranial
nerve 11 which is the accessory nerve so
being what I'm gonna have you do is move
your head side to side up and down okay
and then shrug try to shrug against my
resistance and he does that with ease so
that nerve is intact then we're gonna
place him at a 45 degree angle and we're
gonna have him turn his head to the side
and what we're looking at is the jugular
vein we're looking for any jugular vein
distension jvd so Ben I'm gonna just
turn your head to the side like that and
we're looking for any distinction of the
vein and we do not see any next what
we're gonna do is we're going to palpate
so we're gonna palpate that trachea just
to confirm it is midline and Ben do you
feel any tenderness or anything like
that ask him if he feels any tenderness
and I don't feel any lumps then next
what we're gonna do is we're going to
palpate the lymph nodes all sites of
those and being as I do this tell me if
you feel any tenderness and what I'm
feeling for is any hard lumps or
anything that may be inflamed so what
we're gonna do turn a little bit this
way and there we go we're gonna start at
the pre auricular which is right in
front of the ears then we're going to go
to the back of the ears the posts are
regular then we're going to go to the
opposite battle the parotid jugular
digastric then we're going to go to the
submandibular and then the submental
then we're gonna go to the superficial
cervical and then we're going to make
our way down to the deep cervical chain
and you tenderness so far then we're
gonna go to the posterior cervical and
then right above the clavicle we're
gonna go to the supraclavicular
and did not feel anything and no
tenderness next we're gonna palpate the
carotid artery and this is one artery
that you do not palpate bilaterally you
do one individually so we're gonna fill
on this side and you're gonna find it
next to where the groove of the neck and
next to the trachea and his is nice and
bounding it's two plus then we're just
going to fill on the other side and same
strength two plus then lastly what we
want to do is we're going to auscultate
the carotid artery and you're going to
do one side at a time and you're going
to compare sides and you're gonna listen
with the Bell of your stethoscope and
we're listening for a bruit which is a
swooshing sound so being what I want to
do is I'm going to have you breathe in
breathe out and hold it for me okay go
breathe in breathe out okay breathe
normally now did not hear it on that
side okay breathe in breathe out for me
and hold it okay and I did not hear a
bruit on that side as well so that wraps
up how to assess the head and neck and
don't forget to check out that video
that demonstrates the complete
head-to-toe assessment thank you so much
for watching and don't forget to
subscribe to our channel for more videos